let's talk a little bit about the
traction i think you've been pretty
upfront about
the first half of this year you did
eight million dollars
yeah just a little over eight million
dollars in the first half of the year
okay so eight million dollars in six
months you're doing over a million
dollars a month when we met you were
doing 6 000 so
since that time you have 200 x or
whatever it is revenue
let's talk about that journey over the
last say 2017 18 19 20
and it just ran so it's been about five
years of growth here but getting to a 16
million
run rate in five years for a consumer
subscription service
pretty darn hard what are the key
moments
in the growth of the company that led
you to figure
out that there was a market here for a
subscription service
without hardware just to track people's
workouts and that's what fitpod does
you pick your workout you pick what
equipment you have and it will tell you
through machine learning how your
body is reacting to that workout and
what you should do in the next workout
correct
yeah that's correct it'll construct the
next workout for you so the next time
you're ready to work out whether it's at
home whether it's at the gym
you open the app you know exactly what
you need to do and as you log more
workouts of course
the app will understand your tendencies
and capabilities and get better
and more catered and really advance you
along in your fitness that's what we had
there and
i think to your question what were the
indications where we started to say hey
you know this is actually something
that's really good and i would say that
very early on we knew that we had built
a product that people loved like we
talked about with the incubator
and then soon after that we were talking
with near ayala the the author of hooked
and the book talks about the feedback
loop
where you start to build habits and
that's the trigger the action the reward
and then the investment phase that goes
into the next next cycle
which triggers you to go work out again
and near al really
enjoyed this model that we had and he
actually
wrote us into a chapter of you know the
book to sell the newest release the [ __ ]
has this as a chapter and you start to
see us having that kind of traction and
engagement where people are coming back
to us
and the kind of retention that i think
is far
is a really good number for retention in
this space
relative to others in this space and i
think with that we're able to build on
our subscription business where month
after month or year after year we're
building on our user base
to come in and really enjoy the product
to remain retained in the product
and to tell their friends about it so
you took your time in those early days
making sure the product was not a leaky
bucket as we say in the industry
that people didn't in the fancy word we
use in our industry for quit
what was the process of figuring out
who your customers were and how to not
uh make them churn what can you teach
the audience about that process
and that discovery process how do you do
it as a founder as a product designer
yeah listening to our customers from
very early on we were the ones
speaking with our customers getting them
on you know phone calls video calls
interviews and that mechanically how do
you
ask a customer to get on the phone with
you without it being creepy and weird
um yeah i don't think it's creepy or
weird at all
we have customers write in all the time
saying that they love the product
and if we are able to say hey here's an
opportunity for you to talk with the
founders of the company
to help us make this product better for
you a lot of people
are more than happy to jump on the phone
with us and really explain to us their
experience of how they're
interacting with the product and early
on we had that luxury right we were
small i remember answering emails myself
to to users
to say hey here's actually how we
respond to customers
and as we've grown we've definitely
tried not to let that go
where we still have user researchers
that we're working with to interview
customers
and jesse even today is still getting on
the phone getting on a beautiful with
our existing customers
to make sure that we can continue to
make better products for them so very
simple process somebody writes in they
like the product and you have a public
email address for feedback
you say hey can we jump on a zoom call
and talk for a couple of minutes about
how you use the product what you like
about it what ideas you have
so it's really just finding the people
who are already passionate and engaging
with them
and doing what we call in the industry a
user interview
exactly early on it was as simple as
that today now we actually
have people fill out surveys and one of
the questions in the survey is
would you like to talk with the team and
then we actually break it on the cohorts
right there's people who are power users
of fitbot that we of course want to talk
to
there's people who have churned that we
want to talk to as well so uh definitely
different cohorts that we go out and
talk to to make sure that we're
able to improve the product for them
okay some people
only believe in organic growth they
don't believe in paid other people
are just experts at paid and they don't
really think about
organic growth how do you think about
your business
and scaling it in this combination of
organic growth
word of mouth versus spending money to
get people into the product and
the relative strengths and weaknesses
and how you deploy your resources
to capture both those opportunities
because i would think these are two very
different disciplines i would say that
they may be different but they are
connected and what i'm saying
what i mean by that is when we started
early on we actually didn't do any
marketing
at all and we were all organic all word
of mouth all people
talking about us and you can see signals
in different places social media emails
where people are talking about us and
that was early on
and then we layered in paid user
acquisition on top of that
and because the organic growth was
strong
that's what allowed us in my opinion to
really be successful at paid user
acquisition
and continuing to improve their product
and then continue to layer in
increases to our marketing spend i think
they go hand
in saying hey the effectiveness of paid
user acquisition is going to be
dependent on
the core product and how much people are
enjoying it and telling their friends
about it so
i think they're definitely very
intertwined
let me just say up front go to
linkedin.com unicorn and post your job
for free that's it
i'm giving the call to action upfront
linkedin.com unicorn get your first job
for free and here's why you should do
that
it's because many small business owners
are super busy today we all know that
you're searching for and interviewing
the wrong candidates for a job opening
would be better spent growing your
business we all know this
and you get so many people applying who
are not qualified it's hard
linkedin jobs makes it easier to get the
right candidates
who are worth your time interviewing and
it's fast and it's free you can create a
free job posting in minutes
on linkedin jobs and you'll reach the
world's largest professional network of
over 750 million people
you know this because you're on linkedin
every week probably using it multiple
times a day if you're like me
and you can focus on candidates with the
skills and experience
you need and use screening questions to
get your role in front of
only the most qualified people and those
screening questions are great for
filtering out people who are serious or
not
then you use simple tools on linkedin
jobs to quickly filter and prioritize
who you would like to interview and
eventually hire we love linkedin jobs
here at launch and in 2021 we've hired a
third producer curriculum designer and a
couple of researchers who are crushing
it once again linkedin jobs will help
you find the right candidate
worth interviewing faster every week
nearly 40 million job seekers visit
linkedin
so post your job for free at
linkedin.com unicorn to post your first
job for free terms and conditions apply
because they're giving you a free job
listing okay